vidalia botello 43 ans a reçu un
diagnostic de cancer du sein il y a un
an après avoir subi une mastectomie des
traitements de chimiothérapie et
radiothérapie
cette mère de famille est plus en forme
que jamais mais elle s'inquiète pour ses
enfants sont ils porteurs des mêmes
gènes anormaux
j'aurais aimé sont infestés pour savoir
si j'ai le jem du bea s'est inversée à 2
g pas l'historique familial
mais puisque j mais j'ai des enfants
soit ça peut les affecter
les tests génétiques identifie des
mutations dans l'adn qui varie d'un
individu à l'autre et détermine si une
personne est porteuse ou plus à risque
de développer une maladie
jose paul faire présentement parce que
je le poke les compagnies d'assurances
utilise les résultats de ces tests là
lorsque mes enfants vont aller se faire
vont faire une demande d'assurance un
risque bien réel selon la chercheure
anne-marie laberge médecin généticien au
centre hospitalier sainte justine
les gens soient conscients qu'un
diagnostic chez une personne dans une
famille quand c'est génétique
ça peut avoir des implications pour
d'autres personnes c'est justement la
crête de vidalia botello elle ne veut
pas que sa fille de 22 ans soient
victimes de discrimination génétique par
les assureurs des gens chez qui à cause
d'une sont familiales ont aussi qui sont
à risque de développer une maladie si
l'on pose en musique avec un test avant
qu'ils aient des seins tombent ils vont
être considérée par les compagnies
d'assurance comme étant atteint même si
pour l'instant on n'est même pas sûr
qu'ils vont jamais développé quoi que ce
soit c'est toujours le coeur aujourd'hui
lors du dernier discours du trône en
octobre 2013 le gouvernement
conservateur avait promis de se pencher
sur la question provoque une poêle au
jeu de change compris 24 heures après
cet engagement du gouvernement harper le
sénateur libéral indépendant james brown
déposerait un projet de loi contre la
discrimination génétique les données
génétiques des canadiens ne sont pas
protégés par une loi
contrairement à d'autres grands pays du
monde où à ellen show
pourtant je crois qu'il n'y a rien de
plus confidentielle que votre ado mais
le gouvernement conservateur a rejeté le
projet de loi de sénateurs k-way les
assureurs s'opposent à cette démarche
pour eux les données génétiques font
partie de l'historique médical du
patient que pour les nombreuses
compagnies d'assurance de personnes
l'information découlant de ces tests est
essentielle on n'exige pas les tests
mais on a besoin de cette information là
si on nous interdisait toute
l'information à connotation génétique on
pourrait pour établir les antécédents
les personnes et ça aurait des
répercussions sur la valeur de la france
pour tout le monde
l'actrice angelina jolie avait causé une
énorme surprise en annonçant qu'elle
avait subi l'ablation des deux seins
elle avait une prédisposition au cancer
à cause de la mutation de ces gènes
brca1 brca2 cette mutation des gènes est
aussi observée chez les juive
originaires de l'europe de l'est qui ont
dix fois plus de risques d'être
porteuses de ces gènes que les autres
femmes
richard marceau défend la communauté
juive
il milite aussi contre la discrimination
génétique des familles ont eu à faire le
choix tragique entre soi passer des
tests génétiques et donc trouver des
traitements possibles pour pour leurs
enfants ou encore refusé le traitement
et avoir le droit à une couverture
d'assurance
et c'est très difficile voire impossible
à faire comme choix plusieurs pays dont
la france l'angleterre et les etats-unis
ont déjà à légiférer pour encadrer la
discrimination génétique l'industrie des
assurances au québec affirme que la
grande majorité des demandes de police
sont acceptés ce n'est pas à exclure ces
gens l'os et évaluer le risque
95% des applications sont acceptés les
5% qu'on refuse là c'est pas chez nous
parfois on revient avec une chope rennes
c'est l'individu qu'elle refuse parce
que ça coûte trop cher ça coûte trop
cher avec les progrès de la science de
plus en plus de maladies pourront être
ciblés par des tests génétiques
si on faisait c'était soit entre faire
chez tout le monde
des facteurs de risque
de l'analyse génétique on peut pas
empêcher tout le monde de s'assurer non
plus donc il va falloir trouver un
équilibre pour vidalies a botté l'eau il
faut relancer le débat sur cette
question pour elle c'est un enjeu de
santé publique
aussi ma fille décide de passer les
tests génétiques là peut prévenir la
maladie et faire un suivi médical plus
série et puis tout le monde est gagnant
en bout de ligne
vidalia botello entrevoit l'avenir avec
espoir
elle poursuit son combat pour qu'une loi
contre la discrimination génétique soit
adoptée afin de protéger sa famille
et pour en apprendre davantage notamment
sur les milliers de tests génétiques qui
existe je vous invite à consulter notre
dossier web l'adresse vous la voyez à
l'écran